engineers in San Diego are working on
smart clothes to cool and heat the human
body using fabric that expands or
shrinks in reaction to temperature and
$100,000,000 have just been allocated to
use radio telescopes to search for
aliens Vsauce Kevin here this is mind
blow
researchers at Duke University connected
the brains of four rats
to create a brain net after networking
the for brains via electrodes the rats
were given tasks in memory storage and
retrieval and the brain net performed
better than individual rats did this
technology could revolutionize computing
as well as provide new mental and
physical therapies for stroke victims or
people in comas Oregon State University
researchers have patented bacon seaweed
created from a strain of red marine
algae this new superfood is packed with
minerals and proteins and has twice the
nutritional value of kale but most
importantly when it's fried it tastes
like bacon construction company Volker
whistles hopes to start building roads
out of plastic their proposed idea would
be to collect plastic floating in the
ocean and then process it into sections
of road that could be installed on site
like tiles in theory these roads would
be more durable environmentally friendly
and easier to install than asphalt
however concerns over their safety in
contact with rain or extreme heat must
be addressed before the project can move
forward not to mention the actual cost
of collecting plastic from the ocean the
Hankook eye flex is an airless tire
comprised of three solid sections the
iflix promises a smoother ride more
fuel-efficient driving and it's not only
made out of recycled materials it can
itself be recycled the tire has actually
been in development for several years
but recent advances in the manufacturing
process means they can start moving past
prototyping stages and into performance
and durability testing the in situ
fabricator is a robot that can lay
bricks for construction sites unique in
that it is autonomous the fabricator can
build a 3d map of a construction site
and upload it which means that the robot
can navigate the area on its own it's
not yet ready for commercialization
though as it needs a human to feed it
bricks images of celebrities were used
in mind game experiments to discover how
memories are formed the researchers
would show a subject a photo of someone
like Jennifer Aniston next to the Eiffel
Tower and then monitor which neurons
fired within the brain they found that
if then just shown an image of Aniston
the subjects neurons related to the
Eiffel Tower would also fire up
illustrating that neurons
they're firing properties at the exact
moment that a memory is formed basically
they observed learning the Stella Lux is
a family oriented solar car that
generates more energy than it uses built
to accommodate four people and reach a
speed of 77 miles per hour the Stella
Lux is able to take its surplus energy
each day and return it to the grid in
October we'll be competing in the
Bridgestone World Solar Challenge and if
you pledge 10000 euros to the team I'll
fly you to Australia to take a ride in
the car a new species of Raptor was
discovered in China and it has feathered
wings the Raptor probably couldn't fly
so possible explanations for the wings
include for use in mating displays
protecting eggs or regulating body
temperature the discovery raises
questions about the evolution of wings
now they may have initially evolved for
purposes other than flying Raytheon has
created a see-through aluminum ceramic
that is bulletproof the substance is
half as heavy as traditional bulletproof
glass and twice as effective at stopping
bullets it remains transparent even
after being shot so far the armor is
only used for battlefield lenses or
windows over missile sensors but could
someday allow for even safer windshields
buddy is a new companion robot for your
home he autonomously patrols the house
reminding you of important events acting
as your alarm clock turning off your
lights when you're not around and
alerting you of suspicious activity you
could take control of buddy remotely in
order to check on your home and he can
even act as a party photographer or
tutor for your child and he's being
built to be a robotic modular platform
that a community could program for and
improve finally m-city is a location
specifically built for autonomous
vehicles the types of technologies it'll
be tested out here are both connected so
vehicles communicating with other
vehicles even around blind corners as
well as to the infrastructure and then
various levels of automation all the way
up to fully autonomous will the
automated vehicle detect the pedestrian
in the crosswalk and stop I'm gonna
leave you with tangible Holograms and as
always thanks for watching